you changed my life in a way first of
all you invited me to a wee spa Korean
we spa and we went that became a remote
that was so successful that that led to
you kind of taking me to South Korea
yeah and that is now on Netflix and
everywhere I go
Koreans lose it when I walk into and
people around me are confused but that's
it's this last angle I don't know what
that is the covering the it's the
there's a giant tall white man what I've
noticed though about the Koreans is that
they'll do this and they'll be very shy
and you'll say Sophie Sophie and they'll
be laughing like this and I'll say okay
in the minute we go to take the selfie
they change too which is the real you
I guess they belong both both duality
duality I got it I got it
this is when you need to strike and get
that skin care what like go get that
skin care money get into this Korean
skincare game I thought you were telling
me I'm badly need oh no I knew now that
they know get into the cream you mean I
could do yeah like a big ad there I can
get money selling masks of your faith
like hydrating masks of your literal
face to Korea who is one
maybe pretty good it's a completely
horrible I mean I'm in if the money's
good we'll talk even if the money isn't
good as long as there's some money yeah
Andy you're coming in on this thing sure
no problem yeah yes literal Faceman